depends on the person because growing up
I'm obviously not skinny hi everyone I'm
not skinny so growing up I was never the
beauty standard for anyone so like all
my friends were getting chatted up by
people blah blah blah blah and I was
just the other one you know so like I
never really thought of myself as
an attractive person like I would never
call myself anything more than a thought
but now like I don't really care about
what anyone thinks about me like I've
grown into myself and I've I've I'm
comfortable with who I am now that like
even if I you guys call me delusion or
whatever I think I'm maybe not 10 let's
not go that far but like definitely an
eight per so like whether you guys think
I am or not yeah that's got nothing to
do with her but like what is it that
took you from a four to an eight if
nothing's changed what is it that takes
loving myself and and looking in the
mirror and not being disgusted at what I
see I understand that yeah so but that
doesn't you're you're not necessarily
being objective about how other people
view you right because isn't that what a
rating really is like what you think the
vast majority like like if I rated
myself one to ten I give myself a five I
think I'm normal looking and I just
think it's based on my results I think
if I was in eight nine or ten I would
have had modeling contracts because
people in the top 20 of beauty they get
they get modeling contracts what is
beauty so what what is beauty I mean
there's a lot of things like if you
I mean you can you can go online and
have people rate your pictures and they
rank you one to ten that's wild and and
so you can get you can get a lot of data
that says how attractive you are in
society and men will wait you women will
rate you like every day how we look is
like how we represent ourselves it's not
fun but it's just like being honest
so
um and it's also like you can get dating
apps like you know everyone's Tinder
Bumble like they have a ranking for you
behind the scenes
yeah down yeah well I trust so
um I don't understand when girls say
like I'm an eight because or sometimes I
hear girls say tongues I hear this a lot
where they say like because I love
myself and I'm like confident now but
don't you think attractiveness is based
on results
they may be but I don't care about those
results
to be honest
but do you think then you're not being
objective about your how attractive you
are or how attractive anyone else might
be
um
I guess not but like yeah
that stuff's not really important to me
but I think when when someone when
someone rates somebody why why does that
have anything to do with them like if
you rape me if someone rated like
somebody a three and it's just like okay
that's that's your opinion like it's not
Okay so
my first question is based on this clip
do you think women are honest with each
other no no
what do you think Eddie was sent no no
way
do you think that someone that's
overweight can be above a five
yeah
oh that's a techy one there's men that
like fluffy women like there's
um
how many men
yeah but what do you mean by fluffy do
you know what I think we need to Define
what the like diabetes asthma wait wait
um can you can you Google
um
like BMI chart like do BMI chart
um
something like that
we can decide as a group because I think
you have to define the parameters
because I think have you guys seen Wally
Wally the movie and like all the women
and then the people yeah dude everyone
yeah yeah you're the one with the the
fat the fat one yeah do that yeah there
you go
can you make it bigger yeah yeah thank
you
well
yeah zoom in a little bit
the Red's kind of smaller than I
expected for like the red circle well I
think that's just like the max you know
like that's the minimum Max it keeps
going you know yeah so it can all right
we'll do by color
and I'm not I'm not talking about body
shape obviously these aren't the most
voluptuous woman you know but no cheeks
in them
but just interesting sense
Okay so
um this is on the right on the left does
that say underweight I can't read it I
think yeah the blue is underweight
and then the green is that normal and
then overweight is the the
light yellow so yeah can someone be
attractive or like
above a five if they're overweight
I still say yeah yeah I just think I
think we need to defend the parameters
because attractiveness and wherever a
woman I said above a five above five it
looks wise like one to ten like they're
they're more attractive than someone
that's average if if the body that I
have in mind
goes to be treated 100 okay what about
obese obese it depends on the cheeks so
you think that gut as long as there's
cheese that got it's a Madness but so
then when the answer be now yeah we had
a gut like that what about men there's a
lot of men that also this size that are
deemed attractive or are very successful
with women what do you think about like
what do you mean like ugly guys like it
girls no like overweight guys overweight
guys are still seen as very attractive
are they Rich normally yeah literally
yeah yeah there you go that's like the
cheat code for men I mean like men and
women are weighed on different things so
like men don't care about our money but
matter about women care about men's
money I mean you could argue that maybe
the girls wouldn't have like genuine
desire for them they just want you know
the money but I don't know it depends in
Africa Big Ben is a sign of wealth yeah
that kind of wolf is attractive yeah
like different countries I've like they
force-speed the women to make them
bigger because it seems that's like one
small tribe in Africa and I will agree
and I looked at that tribe because I've
heard so much about this tribe it's like
everyone brings up yeah and that country
is in poverty so it's really not even
the majority of the country it's like a
very it's it's maybe because of that
because they're in poverty maybe like
food resources aren't very common yeah
and then to have those is kind of like a
sign of wealth yeah it's attractive I'm
assuming I don't know I just looked it
up one day and I was like this is the
smallest freaking tribe that I've heard
so much about validating like I'm so
tired of hearing about this tribe
and the other thing is like on the show
I've had so many people tell me like
they won't even tell okay you know I'm
gonna ask the panel this first is lizzo
a 10.
get a picture yeah let's put can we put
lizzo on the screen
let me think just looks yeah look just
appearance one to ten looks including
weight yeah it just looks just looks oh
man
I think that's too hard too I think I'll
go with five I'm gonna say neutral five
yeah five is average you know no like I
feel like she's got a really really
pretty face she's got a very symmetrical
face and you cannot disagree with me I
will never take your opinion on board
I'm talking about her face I I'm talking
about if she even lost weight her
features will come out more like I think
symmetry is very attractive which is a
very symmetrical face to me so I like
her face yeah because you know what when
I hear is she attractive in the face
yeah devoid of her body I think would I
still have sex with her but why is
attractiveness always gonna because I'm
a man but he's a man I was gonna say
he's a man I want to chop for both men
and women chop so yeah but men chop it
but he is like that's like you know yeah
men I feel like just go for what they
see as in like if if you're not if
they're not it says attraction yeah no
the basic principle is the men are
attracted to what they see whilst women
are attractive to what they hear
so that's why men lie and women wear
makeup
I want to agree with you
yeah me but now I look at her face and
think I hate what you're saying
something she's pretty but that's just
me trying to be nice like I would not
give up okay one to ten Eddie one to ten
she's a she's a one
like I feel like one would be like
something that's a little bit more like
300 pounds no like 300 pounds no like
like the face that you could make a
little space look worse is what I'm
saying yeah I mean I don't think she's
like like if if she was thinner she'd be
fine but she's 300 pounds but I don't
think she's a one I feel like the one
give her two
what about you what you think I don't
know I'd say um okay me just being
outside the whole motion I would say
four but then if someone was to come to
me if like someone I like if my
boyfriend wants to come up to him be
like listen I'm leaving you for her I'd
be like are you serious
your self-esteem is gone
so what did you give her a one and your
opinion probably matters the most you're
rating thank you why does it matter
because he's that
he's done in terms of a sexual mate a
relationship everything
can be attracted to women too yeah I
know but I'm just saying would you would
you would you because are you attracted
to women too okay so would you date
lizzo she's not my type
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible